hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great day and if you're wondering
what's up well I'll tell you what's up
today my channel hit 100,000 subscribers
so I'm beyond happy about reaching this
milestone and I will tell you some more
information about how I will celebrate
this occasion I will have I will hold a
live stream on Friday you will be
notified about this I will make a
separate video for this game I thought
I'd show you one of the games between
Magnus Carlsen and Andrew tank also
known as the pet penguin on leeches I
was played in the leeches titled arena
the last one I believe and it's quite an
interesting game featuring a theme that
you'll probably want to remember in your
own games so let's see this game across
and has the white pieces in this game
and he opens with d4 we have d5 Knight
to f3 Knight to f6 c4 and a 6 so
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined at Knight to c3 Bishop to e7
Bishop to g5 h6 now kicking away the
Bishop Bishop to h4 and we have castles
here III b6 now a penguin goes for the
turtle power defense and here Carlson
lashes out with g4 and g4 is a is a
common move probably you don't want to
do something like this in a serious
tournament game but for a blade for a
bullet game it's it's more than welcome
so what's the idea up here behind this
g4 move well obviously white is offering
black to capture it if you play Knight
captures on g4 then you get something
like Bishop captures Queen captures and
after C capture see captors and Knight
captures White gets back the pawn and in
the end there for something like Queen
to d6 and I'd back to c3 black is not
worse here maybe even better but the
white will have some attacking chances
with rook to g1 Bishop to d3 maybe c4
and you know the game is is being played
but if you're not comfortable with this
don't I mean you don't have to grab the
pawn
so after this g4 move penguin played D
captures on c4 and we have rook to g1
now putting a rook on the G file as the
G file will soon be opened Atlee
Costin hopes it will and now the jeep
one is protected as well so nice the d5
and Knight to d5 is a correct idea you
want to exchange as many pieces as you
want now offering an exchange of Bishops
and seemingly offering an exchange of
nights here so Carson plays Bishop
captures on e7 we have Queen captures
and now g5 immediately threatening to
play G captures on h6 and open this open
this G file penguin plays h5 not
allowing the joopa file to stay closed
the to open and we have nice to e5 now
and here you wanna get rid of this
Knight
this is this is the most important move
of this game Knight captures knight on
c3 as you can see sorry the knight on c3
has a clear way into into tanks defenses
with Knight to e4 followed by Knight to
f6 but he leaves the knight on the board
sorry this is weird he plays g6 here we
have Bishop captures on c4 and again you
want to capture this Knight
this is a must must play move we have
Bishop to b7 now comes Queen to c2 and
here we have Knight to d7 again leaving
that night on the board and here Carlson
waits no longer he plays in Knight
captures on g6 and now you don't really
have any other options about the capture
the night as the knight is attacking the
Queen and the rook so if you don't
capture it you're you're losing the
exchange at least so we have F captures
Queen captures with the check and you
don't have a lot of options here you can
either go King to h8 or you can block
with the Queen problem would block in
with the Queen after Queen to g7 is
Queen captures on e6 now as you can see
now there's a triple attack on this
night and d5 and if you want to block
this with Queen to f7 although none of
the moves are particularly good for
black after block this simply captures
captures and now Knight captures on d5
the problem is if you capture the knight
then Bishop captures would check and
also you lose the roof na8
so after you remove the King now comes
Knight captures on c7
your rook is attacked on e8 and if you
move the rook you get nice to e6 check
d6 square is defended by the
and this will fork the rook and the king
so you're losing this game completely
black is falling apart
so after this Queen captures an g6 move
of course not Queen to g7 but we have
kink to h8 defending Bishop comes to d3
now and not allowing any defenses by
Queen to h7 as now the h7 Square is
covered twice Queen to have 7 here
penguin offers a trade of Queens we have
Queen to h6 check King moves and now we
have a queenside castle by Carlsen and
this this queenside castle actually gave
a penguin one more chance to capture the
knight on c3 because Carson in the speed
of battle probably feared the Queen
captures on f2 but now was the ideal
moment to play Knight to e4 as 9:24
really threatens now Knight to f6 check
and Knight from afar is also defending
the f2 pawn but instead of 94
he played queenside castle and this was
the last opportunity penguin had to play
Knight captures on c3 and not allowed
this night to jump into the game but he
played rook 88 and now it's all over now
finally Carlsen plays Knight to e4 and
now there is no good move that prevents
Knight to f6 check in the game Queen to
g7 was played offering a trade of Queens
and also kind of making an escape route
for the King on f7 but Knight to f6
comes this is not with check and your
only options are King to have 7 or
capturing the knight but neither of this
these options is particularly good as if
you capture it then comes pawn captures
this opens up an attack from the roof to
the Queen and you can save the queen but
that's the least of your concerns after
we play something like rook to f7
blocking simply captures cap King f8 and
now Queen to HH and this is checkmate so
after this Knight to f6 move we have
King to have seven trying to escape but
now comes g6
this is with check again only move is
king - king to e7 or King captures night
if you're looking to e7 then the King is
no longer defending the Queen we have
Queen captures on g7 with check
roblox Queen captures King d8 and Queen
captures night and d7 this is checkmate
so in the game after g6 check penguin
played King captures on f6 and now I'm
sure you can all find the winning move
for white without even stopping the
video the move Carlsen played and I'm
sure you all see it now was Queen to g5
and this is checkmate
the queen is covering all of these
squares evenly 7 and the pond and g6 is
covering f7 so there is nowhere for the
black King to go to so yeah that's one
of the games as you all know cause
someone that reaches title arena as well
and one of the reasons I decided to show
you a nice fun game like this is because
I've been receiving all of your
congratulations messages the entire day
and I haven't even been able to respond
to half of them so I hope I will have
managed to respond to all of them as you
know I'm very happy that you you've
congratulated me on this achievement of
reaching 100,000 subscribers and another
reason I decided to show you a game from
the leeches tidal arena is on Friday
were when I will be making my 100,000
subscribers stream I will also be having
an official Lee chess tournament with
prizes so leeches will announce this on
their under website so I do hope most of
you will be able to come like I said I
will make a separate video announcing
everything there will be some giveaways
there will be some other announcements
to make but I will make a separate video
on this so you will be informed no
worries so those are the reasons I chose
this game and well I mean they're very
popular guys both penguin and constant
so I thought why not so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Homer Aziz Chiron Michael story
dummy platelets William Avery open
Fleming at enira and Jonas barrack Jonas
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
most likely with a mcdowel teil game as
as it's customary on this channel when I
I reach a certain milestone I will show
a nice Michael tall miniature so until
then see you soon